[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre recette 8 dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 27 septembre
le Moulin de Saint-Cyr-l'École est en
cours de démolition bâtiment symbolique
situé au bout du parc du château de
Versailles il va laisser place à un pôle
média durant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 puis va devenir un parking on
fait le point en début d'émission après
l'hôpital Mignot au généraux concours et
le centre hospitalier de Poissy
Saint-Germain c'est au tour de l'Hôpital
Privé de Trappes d'accueillir un robot
chirurgien baptisé DaVinci X il pourra
être utilisé pour des opérations au
niveau de l'abdomen de l'utérus ou de la
prostate cette année le château de
Versailles célèbre c'est 400 ans pour
l'occasion la prestigieuse galerie de
l'histoire vient d'être rénovée au total
120 œuvre retrace l'histoire du domaine
dont certaines sont exposées pour la
première fois et puis comme d'habitude
l'invité du 7 8 en deuxième partie
d'émission le concours créatrice
d'avenir qui accompagne et récompense
les femmes chefs d'entreprise en
Île-de-France revient on en parle avec
son ambassadrice dans les Yvelines
Sophie fourneau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le Moulin de Saint-Cyr visse ses
derniers instants au de 20 mètres ce
bâtiment emblématique construit en 1932
produisait à l'origine de la farine le
chantier situé à proximité immédiate du
parc du château de Versailles entre dans
sa dernière phase de démolition les
intérieurs de l'édifice ont été abattus
et l'extérieur et désormais grignoté par
des engins mécaniques
c'est la partie plus compliquée c'est ça
ce qu'on est obligé de mettre un tapis
de bémol pour protéger les shoots sur
les gens et tout ça pendant des années
ce bâtiment était la source de
négociation de non compréhension à la
fois des Saint-Cyriens à la fois des
architectes des bâtiments de France
parce qu'il venait en fait comme un mur
devant la perspective du château et
notamment de la chambre du roi
accélérer grâce à l'arrivée des Jeux
Olympiques sur Versailles ce projet
accueillera un pôle provisoire pour les
médias à l'été 2024 dès la fin des
épreuves les travaux débuteront pour
créer un parking paysager de 150 places
accessibles en 2025 il permettra plus de
confort et de sécurité pour les
visiteurs du parc du château ces 10
dernières années vous aviez très
régulièrement le long de la RDC des
familles qui venaient qui stationnaient
et vous aviez des enfants qui sortaient
de la voiture sur une RD qui est quand
même assez empruntée la phase de
destruction devrait s'achever d'ici
mi-octobre l'État la Région
Île-de-France Versailles Grand parcs et
le département finance l'ensemble des
travaux de démolition et de construction
estimé à environ 9 millions d'euros
[Musique]
on met en place ce qu'on appelle le
mentorat éducatif donc le mentorat
éducatif c'est un programme qui vise à
créer des binômes entre un enfant qui
rencontre des difficultés dans son
parcours scolaire et éducatif avec un
étudiant qui deux heures par semaine va
se rendre au domicile de l'enfant il y a
un autre programme qu'on appelle
volontaire en résidence donc là qui
mobilise des volontaires en service
civique qui interviennent au sein d'un
établissement scolaire
[Musique]
dans le prolongement de la rentrée
scolaire chaque année la fève organise
donc la Journée du refus de l'échec
scolaire qui rassemble les acteurs
associatifs et institutionnels qui sont
mobilisés dans la lutte contre les
inégalités
cette année donc c'est la 16e édition et
le thème tourne autour de des inégalités
face à la lecture donc là il s'agira de
mettre en évidence les enjeux sociaux
qui sont corrélés à l'apprentissage de
la lecture
on se rend compte aussi que la pratique
de la lecture elle est corrélée au
statut social et au capital culturel de
chaque famille et que notamment dans les
quartiers les plus défavorisés ce sont
des pratiques qui sont beaucoup moins
développées que dans d'autres quartiers
et entre 0 et 7 ans un enfant qui va
bénéficier d'une lecture du soir au
moins de voix deux fois par semaine va
plus facilement réussir à l'école
[Musique]
après l'inauguration de deux robots
chirurgicaux dans les centres
hospitaliers de Versailles et de Poissy
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est au tour de
l'Hôpital Privé de l'Ouest parisien
situé à Trappes de bénéficie de cette
technologie le nom de ce robot Da Vinci
x financé à plus d'un million d'euros
par le département il permettra de
maintenir une offre de chirurgie en
cancérologie de proximité ça va nous
aider à être plus précis dans le geste
et donc d'avoir plus d'efficience dans
la gestion dans le traitement du cancer
et dans la limitation des effets
secondaires principaux qu'on peut avoir
parfois dans certaines chirurgies les
conducteurs de bus Keolis à Montesson
ont entamé leur troisième semaine de
grève depuis le rachat de leur dépôt par
Keolis les salariés constatent une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail parmi elles l'absence de
versement des primes d'intéressement et
de participation une reprise de
l'activité mais pour le moment pas
prévue par les salariés
suite aux nombreuses affaires de
harcèlement scolaire en France et
notamment dans les Yvelines le
Gouvernement présente ce mercredi 27
septembre son plan contre le harcèlement
scolaire les particules autour de trois
axes prévenir détecter et sanctionnés
plusieurs mesures sont prévues avec
notamment une grille d'auto-évaluation
proposée aux élèves pour se situer sur
une échelle du harcèlement une autre
mesure concerne la confiscation des
téléphones portables ou des réseaux
sociaux dans le cas de cyber-harcèlement
c'est le dispositif en cas
dépressurisation de la cabine un masque
oxygène tombera aux thématiquement
devant vous c'est un lieu où d’ordinaire
il n'est pas autorisé de pénétrer et
pourtant le temps d'une journée le siège
de safran aerosystème a ouvert ses
portes aux familles de ses
collaborateurs pour une visite unique de
son site et de ses activités quand vous
prenez l'avion vous avez entendu les
consignes de sécurité ou les équipages
vous parlent de des situations d'urgence
et bah tout ce que vous avez sur la
plaquette peut être fabriqué par safran
et au système les masques oxygène les
radeau de sauvetages les toboggans
d'évacuation mais aussi et ça les
équipages ne vous en parlent pas des
systèmes pour la gestion du fioul du
carburant dans l'avion ou pour la
gestion des fluides dans l'avion nous
avons une très grande palette
d'activités et c'est ce que nous
présentons aujourd'hui
les masques oxygène destinés au pilote
d'avion le masque est accessible il est
rangé dans une boîte à masque et il se
met extrêmement rapidement sur le visage
vous l'essayez il faut il faut donc vous
appuyez vous le mettez sur ça marche
avec les lunettes on a aussi des pilotes
avec des lunettes vous mettez
[Musique]
et vous respirer normalement nos
collègues de sa franchise sont exposés
un siège de de classe à faire qui est
extrêmement confortable mais nous
montrons aussi ce que nous faisons en
termes de jaugeage de carburant nous
montrons nos ateliers nous montrons là
où on travaille tous les jours et c'est
aussi l'occasion de rentrer dans les
ateliers dans lesquels d'habitude on ne
peut rentrer que si on est spécialement
équipé avec plus de 1000 salariés sur le
site de plaisir les familles étaient
nombreuses à venir découvrir le lieu
très chouette très bien organisé et puis
ça donne l'occasion à la famille surtout
aux enfants de voir où travailler leurs
parents et c'est une première une
première fois de pouvoir avoir un métier
réel ou un lieu de travail en tout cas
donc ça peut donner des idées et
peut-être créer des vocations présents à
plaisir depuis plus de 60 ans
aujourd'hui ça prend aérosystème et
leader mondial dans de nombreux domaines
comme les équipements d'urgence et les
systèmes carburants
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous présenter casino un
film de Martin scorses de 1995
évidemment quand on pense à martini
Scorsese on pense aux affranchis on
pense à taxi driver on pense plus
récemment à Shutter Island et on pense
un peu moins à casino qui pourtant un
film que en tout cas que moi j'aime
beaucoup donc construit le parcours du
personnage par Robert De Niro dans le
monde des casinos Las Vegas où il est
mis en charge de s'occuper d'un casino
et de tout ce que ça vient donc un film
à la frontière
des gangsters de la légalité voilà avec
toutes les images des pilons qu'on a de
Las Vegas entre l'argent roi
la mafia des frontières qui sont
évidemment très très heureuses et
surtout c'est un film pour moi en tout
cas qui contient aussi tout ce que fait
scorses que soient les longs plans
ostedicats à travers le casino un demi
rock et complètement habité par le rôle
un film qui nous emmènera dans un hiver
ou qu'on connaît on a envie de découvrir
l'arrière il faut dire les casino c'est
quelque chose qui fait toujours un petit
peu rêver le public on sait jamais ce
qui se passe derrière les portes et
voilà c'est un film qui nous y amène
évidemment de façon romancée mais pareil
c'est quand même un film aujourd'hui
quand on a l'image de Las Vegas quand
l'image de ce monde là on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser à casino et qui est
peut-être pas le film de scorsa le plus
connu mais qui est pour moi un excellent
film casino c'est aussi un film qui a
inspiré évidemment romancée mais de
personnages qui ont existé sur ce monde
là scorses a toujours essayé dans dans
son cinéma d'avoir une base de réalité
et donc ce qui renforce de façon cette
impression que que ce qu'on voit est
quasiment réel et surtout c'est un film
notamment qui a été aussi extrêmement
acclamé par la critique pour la
performance incroyable de Sharon qui
joue sa femme évidemment que ce sera
fini ce concept sans jouer au Pachy qui
est aussi là pour jouer le bras droit
quand il faut aller casser des têtes
voilà encore une fois un casting 5
étoiles de ce corps 16 toute la
signature de son cinéma etc et un film à
voir
[Musique]
relais de chasse que Louis XIV son fils
aimait beaucoup il a bien bien aimé
cette atmosphère dans ce lieu un peu
abandonné marécage et petit à petit
l'idée d'en faire un très beau palais
pas encore un palais du gouvernement le
siège de l'État ça ça lui vient dans un
deuxième temps et on sait que c'est en
782 qui décide d'installer la cour à
Versailles pour des raisons aussi
stratégiques s'éloigner un peu de Paris
et puis Louis XV bien sûr va lui
succéder son arrière petit-fils qui
règne 50 ans aussi qui va pas beaucoup
changer l'architecture mais énormément
l'intérieur du du château et puis
construire quand même quelques nouveaux
éléments importants mais en 1789
l'histoire du château et bouleversée le
5 octobre sous Louis XVI les
révolutionnaires envahissent le château
et saccage les lieux le destin du
château après la Révolution continue à
être non seulement riche passionnant
mais presque aussi vivant on a
l'impression que ce château est devenu
un organisme vivant d'accord le la
monarchie a disparu en France mais le le
château de Versailles existent toujours
en 1830 sous Louis-Philippe Versailles
devient un musée le lieu se transforme
une nouvelle fois et car Versailles ne
cesse jamais d'évoluer le château à
repensé l'exposition de manière
immersive avec des vidéos et des
reconstitutions 3D donc ce sont de très
belles de vidéos des montages de de
fragments de films de de d'image
anciennes l'idée vraiment d'accompagner
puisque évidemment quand on parle par
exemple de du grand chantier de
restauration du château à la fin du 19e
siècle on a des images merveilleuses
tout ça vous montre le toutes ces
strates de travaux d'efforts permanents
pour pour sauver le château et donc il
n'y a que de multimédia qui permet
d'évoquer tout ça une chose est sûre
même 400 ans après Versailles n'a pas
fini de nous révéler tous ses secrets
[Musique]
demain matin nous devrions avoir de
belles éclaircies dans les Yvelines au
niveau des températures il fera encore
assez douce 16 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
et Versailles et 15 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet demain après-midi nous
devrions avoir des conditions météo
similaires un ciel nuageux avec quelques
éclaircies côté température il fera 20 à
21 degrés en moyenne sur l'ensemble du
département et demain nous fêterons la
saint vanessas tout de suite l'invité du
7 8 avec Régine raves
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
créatrice d'avenir un concours pour
accompagner les femmes chefs
d'entreprise et les récompenser et pour
en parler aujourd'hui Sophie Fourmaux
bonjour alors vous êtes ambassadrice de
cette édition 2023 est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu plus de ce
concours oui tout à fait le concours
créatrice d'avenir et dédié aux femmes
qui ont soit créé une entreprise soit
qui en reprennent une ou soit qui sont
associés mais qui ont plus de 50% de
part dans l'entreprise il faut que
l'entreprise soit domiciliée en
Île-de-France et c'est un concours qui
récompense l'ambition et une vision
entrepreneuriale après il faut concourir
dans l'une des cinq catégories du
concours innovation quartier
savoir-faire il y a également le prix
public et après il y a le prix vraiment
summum qui est le prix créatrice
d'avenir quelque chose de phare aussi
dans ce concours c'est le prêt d'honneur
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
peu en quoi ça consiste oui tout à fait
donc c'est en fait pour chaque catégorie
donc il y en a 5 il y a une de 4500
euros pour chaque gagnante et suite à
cela on peut bénéficier du prêt
d'honneur par initiative donc le prêt
d'honneur en fait c'est un prêt qui est
personnel que l'on contracte avec un
prêt de avec un prêt bancaire pour le
développement la création la reprise
d'entreprise mais ça va de perdre ici un
concours qui a quand même du succès
aujourd'hui combien combien de
candidatures est-ce que vous enregistrez
à date aujourd'hui alors dans les
Yvelines il me semble qu'on est à 50 un
peu plus de 50 dossiers envoyés
réceptionné alors on va aussi revenir
sur votre parcours parce que vous êtes
aussi une ancienne participante de ce
concours vous avez justement développé
un atelier de rénovation d'abat-jour
quel a été votre déclic pour vous
inscrire à ce concours en 2020 alors en
2020 je voulais m'inscrire pour pouvoir
développer mon entreprise parce que
j'étais dans une taille critique où il
fallait vraiment un coup de boost aussi
bien en termes de presse de visibilité
et puis aussi financier il se concourt
créatrice d'avenir m'a permis d'avoir
les deux et qu'est-ce que ça vous a
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça vous a
apporté en termes de chiffres d'affaires
de visibilité alors j'ai eu beaucoup de
retombées médiatiques j'ai eu un avant
après en termes de clientèle et de
chiffres d'affaires ça pratiquement
doublé quand même mon chiffre d'affaires
il y a une fierté de la part de mes
clients déjà existants et j'ai eu des
nouveaux clients qui sont venus grâce à
la notoriété que j'ai eu dans la presse
et ensuite ça a suscité également des
vocations j'ai pu engager des apprentis
et j'ai pu également embaucher alors
grâce à ce statut aujourd'hui vous
pouvez aussi inspirer est-ce que c'est
important pour vous d'avoir
cette influence sur les femmes qui
souhaitent entreprendre aujourd'hui oui
c'est assez important parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de freins que nous les femmes
nous pouvons nous mettre et ça permet
aussi de on va dire démocratiser
entrepreneuriat au féminin donc oui
c'est je trouve que c'est très important
de de transmettre en fait cette
expérience et aussi de dire c'est oui
c'est peut-être difficile mais c'est
faisable les femmes parce que les femmes
elles ont encore peur aujourd'hui de se
lancer oui pour la plupart oui il y a
quand même des freins qu'elle se mettent
soit parce que c'est pas la bonne
période dans leur vie soit parce
qu'elles priorise leur vie personnelle
et elle se disent non c'est pas le
moment alors que c'est peut-être le
moment pour elle et également elles se
mettent plein de freins notamment
financiers ou elles ont peur un manque
de confiance aussi en elle ça peut être
ça bien merci Sophie fourmeau d'avoir
accepté notre interview si vous aussi
vous souhaitez participer vous avez
jusqu'au 37 ans pour envoyer vos
candidatures c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de nous avoir suivi tout
au long de cette édition et je vous
souhaite de passer une excellente soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]